Okay,
I have a lot to talk about today.
Uh,
and we move a one century and
then move into another culture.
Both are very important. It
may move from, um, uh, um,
uh,
17th century England
to 18th century France.
We moved from a situation which was
dominated by civil war chaos and the
yearning for, um, uh, clear run, uh,
and the movie in a, uh, century, um,
you can call it of enlightenment.
And that's where the term
enlightenment comes from,
the French context and
a century of decadence.
Eventually it leads to our evolution.
But before the revolution,
that is a lot of fairly juicy decadents.
So two different epochs
and two different cultures.
Uh, British individualism, uh,
Hobbes and Locke,
we're methodological individualists.
They thought,
uh,
the analysis should start all
of us with the individual. Uh,
you remember hops,
right?
Individual rives and fairs and then he
builds up what society is starting all of
us from the individual,
not the French.
The French are
methodological collectivist.
They believe that is
such a think as society,
which is more than the sum
total of the individuals.
And somehow they know how to grasp it.
So these are the changes,
what UV is. See, uh,
uh, today, there's today
and next Tuesday, then Vba,
we'll be discussing Montesquieu and Ron
Jacques Rousseau before we return to
British individualism or Adam
Smith's and John Stuart Mill.
Don't ask me why this difference
between the two cultures,
but there is an a lasting difference of
today's topic is Montesquieu and I have
a lot of fun stories to tell,
but our try to limit my anecdote
so I can focus enough on,
on the texter and do not
run out of time. Um, uh,
by the end. Okay. So that was Montesquieu.
Uh, uh, he was born and as
Sharis Louis de Second. Dot.
Barone our bread,
um,
was born in 1689 near Bordeaux.
Um,
his father was a former normal family,
but because he was a younger son, he
had to become a mercenary. And the,
in fact he was fighting chirks in Hungary.
He received a law degree in nevertheless
from the University of Bordeaux.
Um, and uh, in 1715,
he did what many atoms? Stock crash
did. He married a val, said woman,
I was wrong. Uh, large tig, uh,
which was helpful for him because
he was not all that very ballsy. Uh,
though he was a noble man.
Uh,
his uncle Voss a bottle do Montesquieu
and when he passed away a shower,
Louis, uh, received the his style at all.
He became Montesquieu
and inherited his office.
The presidency of the parliament
of Bordeaux. Don't think about it,
was not a very big deal and certainly
did not offer income for the luxurious
life,
was not particularly effluence stuff and
was not a particularly powerful stuff.
Now I bet about the times.
Um, well here it is.
Louis cut off the highs of
French absolute is ma'am.
Uh, well he caught him. They,
he was called the Sun King and
here is his emblem. The son, he,
you know, the sun is shining
like the sun. Uh, they are, um,
uh,
he actually claimed the,
that's a famous sentence and important
to understand Montesquieu later,
some work. Uh, I am the state. Well,
it was a kind of an overstatement.
Not Quite. He pretend to,
to be more powerful than he actually was.
The French absolutism shows.
She did show order the cracks and the
bourgeoisie was becoming already quite
powerful under the times
of Louis Carr tours.
But he had the notion of
French glow, ah, the glory,
right. Um, uh,
and he built these wonderful palace of
Versailles showing what Gla or glory is,
uh,
resident to go ride.
Also emphasize,
emphasize the French, go. Ah,
the French are very fun of it.
Okay. The 18th century was
the century of enlightenment.
They call the [inaudible] of Lumiere.
Lumiere means the light.
Um,
well it was the car,
uh,
who transformed philosophy
two words, uh, uh, uh,
the code view cold look of reason.
And that was Yvonne,
which was spreading in 18th century,
um,
uh,
in grant Cardone and thing
in the 1789 revolution.
And we see two major
steps in this direction.
Montesquieu Andrew saw, uh, uh,
well one of the major accomplishment of
the enlightment for the publications of
Aussie Clopay d, uh, the
sort of blood assessor,
a British and cycle encyclopedia
Britannica of digital and Darla and bear.
And they did.
And which put together rationalistic
scholarship of the time.
Well here you have the first edition,
uh,
for [inaudible]. Um, well, uh,
as, uh, Louis Carr course passed
away, his five year old, uh,
great grandson, uh, um, uh,
Louie fifteens and became the king
and root for a very long time.
Now, uh, the,
the K of absolute wisdom men royal
authority continued and the are really
entering now, uh, with, uh, uh, 1715,
um, one, probably the
longest in modern history,
the longest epoch of decadence
and sexual permissiveness.
It's interesting. Kind of seem
to recur in human history. Right?
Then you had a similar kind
of permissiveness and sort
of decadence 1890s until
1914,
probably 1930 and then the 1960s,
of course, right. Then
everything goes, uh,
well this was a time of the scanned.
Well,
um, he was not at particularly
interested in governing, but,
um, he was very interested
in beautiful women. Uh,
well he was quite a good looking
guy when he was young as well.
So I'm sure women very fat
interested in him too. And you know,
the name Madame Pompadour,
uh, was, uh, uh,
the most famous and most influential,
uh,
of his mistresses.
As I said,
it was becoming right at time of
her sexual permissiveness. Uh,
promiscuity,
a ditty vice spread also
affected Montesquieu.
It is a Madame Pompidou,
uh,
indeed a very beautiful person
but not only a beautiful,
she was extremely smart
as as far as we can tell.
He was an intellectual of
very distinguished stays
days he knew or people of the
Enlightenment Voltaire,
uh,
one of the big trouble makers of his
time and he supported the dro and the
project of Aussie Clopay d uh,
which is a,
it was unusual because you know, royal
authority did not really like, uh,
this one.
Well,
and that me just give you a little
ethnography if you are interested.
[inaudible]
a br.
Sure.
They're low lack law.
I wrote a novel about the sexual and
most of this time, which is scar,
the dangerous relationships they liaison
dodger is now there was two movies out
of made of fit and anybody
watched any of these movie?
Nobody watch it. Wonderful movie
where there are two versions.
One by Roger, Vadim, uh,
and that puts the whole story
in French society of its Stein.
And the other one is an
American Ron Stefan Fares.
And it is Glenn close. Uh, uh,
who features in it now? This
is the Pr Luden movie. Okay.
Borrow it. Do, you will have
fun and you'll be, you'll
have an understanding, right?
But meet an 18th century in France was,
and there Montesquieu and Russo
are coming from. And of course,
this is the American version with
Glenn close. She's already, ah,
you know, the person, what
she likes to play, right? Um,
uh, the vicious woman. Okay. Um, now,
uh, Montesquieu, uh, well,
he lives in the century of
enlightenment and promiscuous.
He sells his office though.
I mean,
he made it lifts from the verse of
his wife, a salsa band business,
but then he leaves the van business to
the wife and beginnings to travel in
Europe and in England.
Uh, then when he returns,
he settles in Paris, leaves to
the vive and back, you know,
to run the van business.
And he will be getting to write.
Uh,
he writes a publishes in 1721 already,
the parish and letters.
I talked about this before and then he
was elected on the basis of these two.
Academic, Fran says, uh, the French
academia of sciences and art,
the very big accomplishment
that these very early age.
And finally, 1748, he
publishes doing major book.
Um, it, this is really
a very important book.
I hope you did what I asked you
glance that it not an easy read,
a bit drier than some of the
texts we read, but very important,
fundamentally important
stuff. Did you ask him to, uh,
write something for the Onsie
Gloppy d about democracy?
About he's bored with the
question of democracy.
He wrote enough about this.
So he writes an article on taste.
Okay.
And he died in 1755 and patty,
so these are the times, and
this is your order. Uh, um,
okay.
Montesquieu
MMM.
Oh, let me move on to, uh, the Varick.
Oh
yeah.
So here we go.
This bit is off the laws.
Anti yet is the first edition.
So what is this book?
Uh,
the first part as a lawyer and genital
and different malts of governance,
uh, entered us think,
not pass breaking. Uh,
this is not what he did
be remembered for though.
I mean that he is opening some
very important subject matters.
The second one is law and politics
and separation of powers VVC,
right. He bills, uh,
on lock and takes lock
him a big way for Vod.
Great improvement in many of,
you know,
to the extent that is improvement of
course lock has some insight which is
missing from the Montesquieu and
formulation of separation of powers.
Uh, then he has this extra ordinary
section on low and climate.
This is one of his big contributions.
Uh, um, Ivs. Sure. You,
I mean, the way how he
formulated is extremely naive.
Um, almost borders on
the ridiculous, but uh,
given, uh, the 21st century,
there are very few people with
the exception of [inaudible]
who I named already,
right in the introductory lecture who
was so sensitive that society lifts in
these globe.
Right.
And how society is formed and structured
and how its laws are being shaped is
actually greatly influenced by the
nature of environmental and climatic
conditions.
So he is the first of ecologist.
Here's the first environment artists
thrive who understand the interaction
between social organization,
Morse ethics,
ideas and society. Right. Um,
and then the, that that is a
bit on law and commerce. Ivo,
very briefly talk about this law and
religion and Ivo skip this section or
together. And Lo and history, I also
skipped. So what are the main teams?
First, you know, we'll be about
classification of governments then ivy,
we'll talk about separation of
powers and then an environment,
law and social structure.
These are the issues they
will be rushing through.
There's a lot of staff,
uh, to, uh, uh, uh,
look at it well before Montesquieu,
uh,
the question when they classified
government was who rules,
who is the silver and
Montesquieu changes somewhat.
The discourse is interested
in the manner of governments,
how people who are in authority rule,
uh, uh, the real music distinction,
better government is moderate
or whether it is despotic.
Now, what are the questions? You
know it when you try to judge, uh,
the nature of a government, one important
question you, he said you should ask,
ah, the various power
separated or not. Um,
irrespective who rules, whether it can be
a king, it can be an elected president,
it can be a prime minister.
The question is I have
the power are separated.
And the next question is,
this is very important.
Why do people obey the question,
why people obey orders is Dutch
strip on by hops and lock,
but it's not really elaborated.
This is the issue.
But the will call the
question of legitimacy, right?
What are the principle of why the obey
orders and Vivio see a much later in the
scores at it will be Max Weber's will
elaborate on this issue at great lengths.
Um, and then the next question is, okay,
is the ruler and individual or
is this an institution? Is it,
this is all very interesting
enrichment of the idea.
But the nature of governments are,
he himself supports a constitutional
monarchy at his reports.
Um,
uh,
a monarchy right in which there is
a king or clean but king and clean,
which operates on the rule of law.
That's what constitutional monarchy is.
The second major theme
is separation of powers.
I'm still elaborating what we
are. Come well, you have read,
uh,
lock distinguish between and executive
and federative branches of government.
More skew,
uh,
distinguishes between legislative
executive and you're ready.
Call now. This is the
Vaughn, uh, which is,
has been so influential on the
American constitution about the,
or believe now in this country that these
are the three branches which should be
separated. Though of course,
the federative remains to
be an interesting issue.
Who should exercise federative
powers the powers of war?
Should it a the legislature or
should it be at the executive branch?
Uh, as such now, um,
or Montez cures that the three
powers will have to be separated.
The legislative power,
uh,
and this is a departure
from Hobbes and Locke, uh,
should be by elected representatives.
And then he makes an important,
a new contribution.
And he said the right of
minorities should be respected. Uh,
though he kind of foreshadows
something like universals, um,
um, uh, uh, wall thing though is
not quite explicit about this,
but you can read into it. But then
he said, the minorities, right?
Should it be, um, uh,
reserved? And he said, well,
the legislative power cannot and should
not be held by the monarchs and what it
has to be limited. There must be a
limitation on legislative powers.
Um,
uh,
and the executive bill exercise
checks over the legislature.
Um, and Vivio again, doc
about this in more detail.
Uh,
and,
but there must be some checks and balances
over the executive branch has val,
um, when it comes, you
know, who controls what,
he puts more emphasis on the executive
limiting the legislative stand the other
way around, but, uh,
reveal see what the arguments are and
about the ration of for this is and how
this affects, for instance,
the functioning called
the US government today.
I think it is not all that far of a,
for the blueprint Montesquieu um,
established,
laid back, um, in, uh, uh,
the mid 18th century.
And then the last issue
of VOB environment, uh,
how social conditions are shaped, uh, uh,
by environmental on conditions,
but he said,
but that is also a general spirit,
a spirit which is above the individuals.
And this is the very French team,
right?
You cannot explain it from the individual.
There is some general idea Durkheim vieux
Carre collective conscience Russo via
called it the general veil, right?
The very franchise idea, right?
That there is some consciousness at
both the individual consciousnesses.
This has formulated so
powerful the first time,
um, by uh, uh, um,
Montesquieu and he actually
said a civilization is
progressing the influence of
the natural conditions,
the clients and the importance right of
general spirit increases or to put with
Durkheim, the collective conscience
becomes more and more important.
I'm just foreshadow that
you have a sense right,
that the score three or
the hangs together, right?
They are not talking
about separate orders.
We are talking about a set of orders
who are talking to each other.
They're beating each other,
right?
That's I think what is so fascinating
about the foundations of modern social
food. Um, uh,
that's cannot be said about 20 or 21st
century social theorizing where we are at
each other throats and we
ignore each other, right?
It's a more typical, okay. Um,
as I said, you know, he's a methodology
called call activist, right?
And that just explained this to you. A
little riot methodological individualists.
We'll begins in order to develop
our conception of society,
you have to start with at the individual
the only reality what you can observe
in individual action and
individual consciousness.
Everything else, right? But you
suggest is speculative, right?
This is British individualism
and empiricism, right?
The French emphasizes
there are stuff like law.
This is why the legal system,
the law is so important for Montesquieu.
That's why the major book is called like
the spirit of law because the law is
not simply as some toto right
of individual consciousness,
it sends over us, right? And we
get into a society and the law,
the legal system already does exist.
If will see Naruc handles the same thing.
This is why the legal system
is so important for him. Okay.
Now let's move into the first team
and talk about the different forms of
government.
Now he makes a distinction
between Republican government,
a monarchy, um, and desperate state.
Republican government in his definition
means that either the people,
uh, uh, uh, uh,
rule democracy or a subset of people,
right?
Aristocracy has the silver and
power are the source of law.
Um, as VBL see, he's not all that certain.
Whether the people rule is all
that good, right? He refers,
sort of selected aristocracy.
It will be even true for who.
So he's much more radical
than he is Manara here and
which one alone governance.
Uh, but by fundamental laws,
the monarchy itself is bind by,
by laws. Um, Eh, a desperate state.
Now, there are no fundamental
roles, rather desperate exercise.
It is power at its vale,
um,
of Hitler's Germany or Stalin's
Russia or Soviet Union.
Our desk, Patek stays right where
there is no proper rule of law.
Now about a 30 public hell,
as we said,
there are two forms of it
is the democratic and then
the Edisto cratic farm in
the democratic. You have a selection
of people to office by lot.
Well, he's not, don't get about elections,
but by lot and indeed in Greek democracy,
people were occasionally
selected two major offices,
right? In ancient Greek by
law, by lottery in aristocracy.
People are selected by choice,
right?
The best people get into the office that
they have the best skills to perform.
Now he said, well, everyone can vote,
but not everybody's prepared
to serve in the office.
That speaks right for uh, uh, uh, at his,
at his stock class by choice.
But, uh, whatever the republic is,
that is a principle.
Legitimacy is based on virtue.
The person who served should be virtuals.
Right?
And if the virtuals ness
of the person is question,
then you know, the legitimacy of
the person is in some trouble,
a verb body. The virtuousness,
remember Bill Clinton,
he ran into some trouble,
you know,
because people started to
bastion virtuals ness, right?
In the very narrow sense
of the term. Okay. Anyway,
that's the guiding principle.
Then manner.
Now here the prince has a silver and
power is the source of law or to Mazda law
is established. The prince has to
follow that law. That's monarchy.
And the principle here is honor.
The prince has to be honorable,
right? In order to be obeyed.
Again,
the busiest of legitimacy is honor and
despotism as we have seen a Duvon of who
governance can do whatever it
wants to do is above the law.
Right?
Uh,
and what is the principle
of despotic rule fair,
right? You obey those in
power because you fear that.
Well,
the next is separation of
powers and the see the,
the three powers
that are,
but I the legislative
power executive power,
and they'd be able to see
the power to judge later on.
Executive power over Danks,
depending on the right of nations
executive power over things,
depending on civil rights.
Um,
he said the first power executive power,
uh, uh, uh,
executive legis legislative
power, uh, in fact, uh,
can be exercised by a
king or a magistrate, uh,
can be exercise by even elected body.
But the second one,
executive power, uh, Vale,
it has to be executed.
He believed the, uh, by, um, uh,
usually by a monarch. Uh,
and that is the last power,
the power of judging a Veatch has
to be separated from boss, uh,
the, um, uh,
legislative and executive
power. Let, let's see the
argument, what he puts forward.
He said,
vendor legislative power is United with
the executive power in a single person
that is no liberty. Uh,
because one can fear,
right that the same monarch
who mates died, Dido,
Nicole Ross, Bill, execute them
in a tire and Nicole manner.
So therefore you have to separate
legislative and executive powers.
Well, the separation
is not complete, right?
Because it takes time for the
legislative body to pass laws.
And therefore,
very often executives even in the United
States operate with executive orders,
right?
These executive orders
kind of substitute right?
For laws or legal regulations,
right?
So the separation,
even in modern society like
the United States is relative.
And in fact,
uh,
many constitutional lawyers
in the United States,
we're concerned you in the
last two administrations
that the executive branch to
often operated by executive orders,
right?
Rather than to ask, uh,
uh, the legislature, right?
To legislate about, uh, uh, doors today.
Um, okay. Uh,
now,
um,
he, then he goes on and
he said, look, uh, uh,
this is not really a question of
that at public versus manner. He,
uh,
he said,
look in in his stamps
in most kings of Europe,
but the government is
quite moderate. Um, uh,
he sat val depends who exercises. Uh, uh,
the first two powers a
bell, uh, leaves, uh, uh,
uh,
a great deal of autonomy for its
subjects and the thallium republics.
They are republics in office time,
18th century.
The powers are United and that is
less liberty actually in this Italian
republics. Well, it's
an interesting, uh, um,
buoyant,
uh,
no about the legislative
power. He said, val,
it better to be an elected body,
which exercises the legislative power,
passes the laws,
uh,
and become close to the idea of
universal suffrage in choosing the
representative.
All citizens should have the right to
vote and then comes the qualification
except who city so humble that they are
deemed to have no deal of that all in
order to have a veal, you better
the be a property owner. Right.
That is a suggestion here
of property qualification.
Mitch was quite dominant in the United
States until the 20th century. Right?
Um, uh, uh, in, uh,
Yep.
But on the other hand,
he elaborates on it.
People should not enter government
except to choose their representatives.
I, because in order to be in the
executive, you'll need skills.
Um,
now you may know who would be the
right person to run the office,
but you may not be able to run the office.
That's the fundamental idea.
Uh,
well it's also important,
right, that these representative
body, the legislature,
uh,
should be separated from a actual
action. Now comes the idea, right?
The right of minority.
This is a novel idea cast
in a very conservative way,
but the way it is cast in a
conservative kind of fuel door,
Edisto cratic manner and
that [inaudible] speaking,
he's formulating a very
important principle,
what we are still struggling with,
right?
How to defend the rights of minorities
against a despotism of the majority just
be costs.
51% voted one day does not
mean that 49% is wrong,
right?
And that the rights of that 49% or
even just 1% in some days has to be
guaranteed. And that's what he's
struggling with. Now here in this context,
and we'll put the
citation, uh, on the web,
so I don't want to read
this very long citation.
The argument is for the
nobility, it said, well,
the nobility has more rights and
therefore they have more rights,
more stakes in it. They have
more than one voice. Therefore,
the solution is a two chamber solution,
right?
A chamber for the aristocracy,
upper house and the chamber
popularly elected by everyone,
a lower house. Now, not
in the aristocratic sense,
but in some ways representing the defense,
right?
Of Small States and agrarian states.
This is by the United States Senate.
Every stage since two senators rather,
irrespective of the size of
the population, right? Uh,
and therefore a though
not in a, um, uh, uh,
sort of few dollars stick way as
Montesquieu demented, but it is,
the whole proposition is very much alive,
right.
In our current political practices.
Uh, okay, that's me.
The move on and talk
about the executive power,
the executive power should be stable.
That's why he believes it better
be in the hands of a manner, right?
Because the government
needs immediate action.
It cannot leave right to Massey
Congress to debate things all the time.
Uh,
the government has to act instantly
and therefore it has to be in one hand.
Um,
well there are all of,
he elaborates a number of
limits of legislative powers.
Some of it applies to the United States,
others dawn,
but may apply to Western democracies.
It should convene at regular intervals.
And that's quite true for
all democratic states, right?
The legislature is called
very often, um, uh,
and uh, with some regularity. Well,
it should not be in session without
interruption. Uh, the US, uh,
uh,
um,
congress is virtually right in
session almost without interruption,
but other parliament in continental
Europe or not necesarrily so the reason is
that it, they don't want
to make, uh, uh, uh,
membership in the legislature.
The sole source of occupation and income
and that are being switch speaks for
this idea. Right now the legislature
is not impermanent that a session.
And then he said, that should not have
the right to convene itself. Well, uh,
the u s congress convenes itself.
It does need the car of the executive.
But in England, for instance, right,
it is the queen who dissolves
the parliament and cause
the session of the bottle
on them doesn't give her much power.
But nevertheless, uh, it, uh, uh, the,
the idea,
the more Montesquieu and idea is present
in a number of Western democracies,
um, now, uh, regular intervals,
that's obvious, right?
When it should not be
left to the executive,
especially if the executive has the right
to call into session the legislature,
right?
That may mean the executive veal not
call the new laws are needed and they'll
become a desk buddy. That's
why it has to be, uh, uh,
uh, called by, um, uh, regular intervals.
Uh, uh, and, uh, it, uh, you know, it
should not be in session without
interruption because he said it would
overburden, uh, the
executive power as well. Uh,
and it cannot convene itself.
He said,
and the arguments are known
because if it would, um, uh,
have the right to decide
whether it dissolves itself,
it will never dissolve itself. That's
the fundamental argument here. As I said,
in many countries, this is exercise.
She's very now the executive, he said,
I should be able to check
over the legislature. Uh,
um, and uh, in what way? Uh,
because it doesn't run the
legislature, uh, to, um, uh,
paralyzed the action of the
government. Um, and, uh,
the mean they, uh, how, uh, the, uh,
executive exercises checks over the
legislature is the veto right of the
executive exactly like it is
done in the u s constitution,
right?
Uh,
the president can veto laws
which are passed by Congress,
has to send back to Congress
and the Congress has to
overrule rather the veto of
the president. But there is a
clear light check of the, uh,
executive over the legislature, right? Um,
the executive has the possibility,
uh,
to remind the, uh, uh, the legislature,
this may be a bad idea to pass this law.
You better rethink it
before it becomes a law.
There are checks and balances
over the executive branch.
He is quite a conservative here.
And he said the executive power belongs
to the legislative oldest to its
faculty, uh, Alpha,
uh,
vetoing, uh, the executive power. Uh,
yeah,
it's very important, right? And
Axa, the rising of public funds,
um, uh, uh, uh, uh,
only with the consent of legislature.
This is again,
a very important principle,
the ruling all democracies.
And either the budgets have to be
improved, uh, by the legislature. Um,
just see the mass.
Uh,
what we have seen in California recently,
right by the,
that the legislature was not giving
the budget I have to the governor.
Um, uh, but this is certainly a very
important principle of democracy.
Um, and now, uh,
let me come to the question of environment
and society and the whole idea that,
uh,
the physical condition shape,
uh, uh, uh, uh, uh,
social conditions. And let
me give you a couple of, uh,
as I said, quite silly notes. He said,
the spirit and passion are extremely
different than in various climates.
Laws should be relative to the
differences in these passions.
And now comes the real silly
var call in cold climate,
the blog is pushed harder
or about the heart.
This produces confidence in
oneself and carriage and better,
much so.
You are more courageous,
more active and smarter if
you live in cold climates.
Um, uh, like in France or in England,
people in hot countries
that they made like old man,
I'm not all that teammate. Okay. Um,
and then interestingly,
you know,
to sort of this himself from racism and
that term which did not exist in his,
that is that even the children of
Europeans born inside the end is lose the
courage of the European
climate. At least it is, uh,
uh, uh, uh, uh, not, uh,
based on a racial argument,
but indeed made ms on a extremely
naive ecological argument.
But let me emphasize that is
fantastic insight here. Right? Um,
for another 200 years,
nobody took the environment
seriously. I mean, the,
the exception of Emil Durkheim,
they will talk about this when we talk
about their time coming from Montesquieu
for Durkheim want a secure and Russo
over the goths, right? That's that,
uh,
modern theory of society came from.
It was Montesquieu and
it'll solve a boss of them.
So, uh, and now about the general spirit,
he said many things,
government climate,
that ledger laws,
the maxims of government,
more sun manners.
That is this all s to gather a general
spirit which is formed as a result,
right? I hope you get the idea
of the general spirit, right?
That that is a set of ideas, which is, uh,
both our individual consciousness
in child. Who would we learn,
right?
We internalize those ideas.
It is not coming from the individual.
It is entered into the individual
in the process of education, right?
And therefore,
the argument was Montesquieu makes
repeated by Rousseau and do your crime.
That's the 10 have and should have an
idea off society or collective conscious
neck standing over and
above the individual.
This is a big debate, right?
Which informs most of the,
that Bates in social
sciences today in economics,
in political science and
sociology and anthropology,
you have some scholars who the
God themselves in economics,
few methodological collectivists and
doors will call themselves methodological
individualist, rational
choice people. Right.
Are the methodological individualists,
the cultural analysts are
methodological Glock activist, right?
We have that distinction virtually
everywhere, as I said, least in economics.
But even in economics,
you have the institutionalists,
right, who are on the edge, right?
Or between being methodological or
collectivist or being methodological
individualists. Uh, and then, uh, uh,
well, he says as
civilization on force, uh,
the importance of the general spirit is
increasing and impact of climate is a,
uh, a declining, not that
climate doesn't matter,
but overtime it's important declines.
And the,
the importance of general
spirit increases. Well,
that's about it for today.
Thank you.